welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Wolverine actor Hugh Jackman
just confirmed some major news that
Deadpool 3 is going to cross over with
the corner of the MCU occupied by Loki
in the TVA when Jackman and Ryan
Reynolds announced Wolverine's return in
Deadpool 3 back in September 2022. they
already started to imply that they were
going to lean into the timeline
complications and really make fun of
them and now it's all starting to come
together in the same week that we saw
our first our first footage of Loki too
so I'm gonna break down what we learn
and connect all the dots for you you
know a nice little stocking stuff up
from Santa boss okay in the past week on
siriusxm's Jess Cagle show Hugh Jackman
was asked about his upcoming role in
Deadpool 3 which is slated to come out
in November 2024 but a script probably
underway with Ryan Reynolds and director
Sean Levy Jackman discussed how his MCU
arrival would connect to Logan's past in
the fox X-Men continuity including the
character's death in the 2017 Logan film
all because of this
advice they have in the Marvel world of
moving around timelines now we can go
back
because you know it's science and
and so I don't have to screw with the
Logan timeline which was important to me
and I think probably to the fans okay a
few things here Hugh Jackman reiterates
that Wolverine's MCU crossover will not
erase or retcon Logan's death in the
2017 Logan film this is something Ryan
Reynolds already really stated in the
announcement videos Logan takes place in
2029 totally separate thing Logan died
in Logan not touching that but Jackman
also mentions this device they have in
the Marvel world of moving around
timelines now we can go back because you
know it's science there are two ways we
can interpret this Jackman could just be
referring to a narrative device or a
literal in-universe device by using the
word science maybe referring to a piece
of technology but really in either
interpretation he is referring to
something in the MCU that allows for
timeline manipulation and really the
likeliest thing he's referring to here
is the technology of the TBA from Loki
now yeah sure Avengers end game had
Quantum navigation Through Time vortex
taxes but ever since then game they've
been treating that as a one-off thing
that the Loki series even referenced as
an action existing within Loki's
timeline logic Ms Marvel used the Bengal
to open a rip through space-time
allowing Kamala to go back in time and
save her own grandmother but when I
interviewed Iman villani about that she
confirmed to me that she believed
kamala's actions were part of he who
remains and Kang's sacred timeline
destined plan so Hugh Jackman is
confirming that when Deadpool and
Wolverine enter the MCU in Deadpool 3
they are going to use the TVA rules in
Loki to explain how this happens which
makes Loki season 2 even more important
to the phase 5 lineup and no I'm not
saying that that Lit motorcycle in the
alleyway from the Loki footage is
Wolverine's motorcycle though I guess I
wouldn't hate that either we have been
speculating here on new rock stars that
Deadpool and Wolverine could be
introduced as timeline violators who
were arrested by the TDA kinda like that
possible Peggy Carter cameo in the
background of season one episode one of
Loki but in this case someone in the TVA
like Loki or Mobius
teen or even Casey could just pass a row
of cells in the TBA solitary confinement
in which it's implied that these cells
contain Logan or Wade Wilson that way it
could just be implied that Deadpool and
Wolverine are TDA prisoners without
having to Shell out for Orion Reynolds
or Hugh Jackman Cameo on a Disney plus
series also there was that Twitter
exchange I broke down recently between
Brian Reynolds and an unverified Miss
minutes account an account followed by a
Loki Creator and Avengers Secret Wars
writer Michael Waldron an exchange that
was mostly weird because Miss minutes
tweeted the Deadpool account but then
Ryan Reynolds applied to it from his
personal account completely unprompted
it just seems like Brian Reynolds has
the TVA on his mind as he's figuring out
the plot for this Deadpool 3 movie now
I'm on camera a lot so I have to see my
face a lot so you think I would have to
put a lot of effort in my skincare
routine but you know what I really don't
because I use geology geology is a 15
time award-winning personalized skincare
company recognized in hypebeast birdie
Men's Health and Esquire and Aspen
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews and they've recently expanded to
offer products for pretty much what ever
you need all you got to do is take this
30 second diagnostic quiz and geology is
going to figure out your routine for you
like if you need some hair care well use
geology's co-wash it's a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses the hair without
the big lather the harsh ingredients of
typical shampoo and for the rest of your
shower routine you can use their body
washes they're free of harsh ingredients
they smell great and are refillable and
for after the shower protect your skin
from environmental stressors with
vitamin C plus e for Relic serum to keep
your skin looking young and healthy and
then a bit of dermatologist tested
aluminum free deodorant that really
smells great right now for a limited
time geologists is hooking our audience
up with an absolutely crazy offer use
the code new rock stars they will give
you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skincare trial set that
discount applies whether you're stocking
up for yourself or stuffing someone
else's stocking instead either way
geology has you covered check out their
awesome gift sets featuring all of your
favorite geology products to get started
just click the link in the description
take a 30 second diagnostic quiz and
their team of dermatologists will design
a personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door so let's
game this out Deadpool and Logan pick up
after the credits Montage from Deadpool
2 which was set in the 80s era of the
X-Men Origins Wolverine when Wade killed
his altar itself and he said but one day
your old pal Wade's gonna ask you to get
back in the saddle again
and when he does say yes
oh
so from there Deadpool continued zipping
through time and timelines he killed
Ryan Reynolds the actor before he began
the Green Lantern movie and then he
tried to kill Baby Hitler so I think we
can assume that Wade will make good on
his promise in rejoin his old pal Logan
from some time later in that Logan's
timeline that Logan would not have
reached the point of the 2017 Logan film
in the year 2029 or since he was on a
branch timeline would not have reached
the ending of X-Men Days of Future Past
really I think they want the Wolverine
in this movie to just be a baggage-free
wolverine who carries the basic
Hallmarks of the character like the
tortured past The Loner Spirit a bit of
skepticism toward the X-men group
without all the complicated timeline
trappings of the character trappings
that Deadpool might be aware of but this
Wolverine isn't really beholden to and
just ultimately have fun with the two
characters on a road trip because years
ago Ryan Reynolds did say that he
envisioned a Deadpool 3 script with Wade
and Logan on a road trip in his words
rashamon style it's actually possible
that Deadpool's meddling through time
could get him first arrested by the TVA
alone before he's able to connect with
Wolverine like the TVA might confiscate
Cable's time travel watch as Contraband
and then Deadpool's able to break out of
the TVA steal a temp pad and use it to
go find Logan across the time stream
which she would be able to do because
Sylvie has now stabbed he remains and
broken apart the secret timeline which
might open up Tim pads to Branch
realities but I think it's important to
remember that the Wolverine that
Deadpool connected with at the end of
Deadpool 2 was the one from the part of
the X-Men timeline that had been erased
by X-Men Days of Future Past that movie
went back to 1973 and Changed History so
that things would unfold differently
throughout the 70s and the 80s
retconning everything from that period
of history that had happened in X-Men
Origins Wolverine so Wade was
essentially visiting a detached Branch
timeline that was already pruned out of
continuity or just a branch timeline
that was continuing on its trajectory no
one really cared about anymore this
Wolverine is a lesser variant a
forgotten hero without a future he's a
temporal reject and so Deadpool could
show this Wolverine the X-Man he would
become the way Mobius showed lopi the
character he would become had he stayed
in the sacred timeline as we move ahead
into the Multiverse Saga the MCU is
really becoming the story of timeline
independent time hobos and I'm so here
for it let me know what you want this
Wolverine Deadpool TVA plot to look like
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]